Aslında insanın kendini anlatmasını ben
kendi açımdan çok doğru bulmuyorum bir
EGO yükselmesi gibi hissettiğim için bu
bana teklif edildiğinde çok şaşırmıştım
bir taraftan bir taraftan da Acaba neyi
anlatacağım düşüncesi sarmıştı Çünkü
kendimi o kadar normalleştirmiştim ki
farklı görmüyordum ve bunun süperdi
Araya sesler giriyor bu arada
günün sonu bu daveti bana sunduklarında
her şeyden önce dediğim gibi Neyi
anlatsam Hatta acaba bakanlıkla ilgili
birkaç bilgi falan da mı versek arada bu
konuları da
sesi geliyor değil mi arkadaşlar
ikilemler yaşadım Efendim ben
1976 Hanımlar pek yaş söylemez ama
söylememin bir şeyi yok sakıncası yok
Erzurum İspir Değirmenli köyünde dünyaya
gelmiş
4 çocuklu bir ailenin bireyin
9 aylıkken tandır bilen var mı İçinizde
Bilmiyorum Yeni jenerasyon biraz uzak
Güneydoğu Doğu Anadolu Bölgesi'nde ekmek
pişirmek için yemek yapılmak için
kullanılan bir Ocak modeli Onun
içerisine düşmüşüm 9 aylıkken bu kaza
sonrası 10 parmağım ampute olmuş
parmaklarımı kaybettim Sonra ailem
kazadan hemen sonra İzmir'e İzmir
Karşıyaka'ya yerleşmiş fırıncı bir
ailenin kızıyım
Annem okuma yazması olmayan bir anneydi
babam da okulda yazmayı askerde öğrenmiş
bir babaydı esnaftı
bir engelli çocukla nasıl baş edilecek
konusunda bir tecrübesi yoktu Bir
eğitimi yoktu bir psikolojik Pediatri
bir eğitimi almamıştı ama bir anneydi ve
al içgüdüleriyle belki de aynı
içgüdüleriyle büyük bir mücadele büyük
bir emek verdi Aslında bugün size biraz
da
cümlenin başında söyleyecektim Ama
takdir edersiniz ki heyecan var İşin
gerçeği sizlerin karşısında konuşmak çok
kolay bir durum değil
ben elma ekin tarlasındaki elmaların
hikayesini anlatacaktım size ama konu
içecek karıştı oraya da geliriz inşallah
Şimdi Tabii ki engelli bir çocuktu en
önemli şey anne ve babanın birinci
Eğitmen anne baba Aslında çok çok önem
arz ediyor malumunuz ülkemizde ve
dünyada da Engel oranı çok yüksek
hepiniz mutlaka karşılaşıyorsunuzdur her
birinizi mutlaka birinci olması bile
üçüncü dördüncü derecede Akrabalarınız
yakınlarınız vardır engelli olan
bu oran yükseldikçe sistemin de oran
doğrultusunda değişmesi gerekiyor Ne
yazık ki ben o dönemlerde sistemden
kaynaklı birçok
sıkıntılar yaşamış biriyim Çünkü 7
yaşına geldiğinde artık okul Çağım diye
annem beni okulun kapısına
götürdüğünde okul şöyle bir cevap
vermişti onlara Kusura bakmayın ama
Çocuğunuzu Ankara'da engelliler okulunda
okutabilirsiniz biz okul olarak Engelli
çocuğu okutabilecek kapasitede değiliz
diğer çocuklarında psikolojisini
düşünmemiz gerekiyor gibi bu mealde bir
cevapla Annem geri dönüp gelmişti yine
dediğim gibi okuma yazması olmayan Anne
bu cevap sonrasında
6 ay boyunca bana kalem tutmayı
öğretmeye çalıştı
bir o dönem iki kardeşim okulda okuyor
akşam onlar geldiğinde onların kalemleri
ile defterleriyle benim kalemimi nasıl
tutabileceğim konusunda büyük bir
mücadele verdi ve ben bu mücadelenin
sonrasında hakikaten 6 ay sonra kalemi
çok güzel kavramış artık çizgileri
vesaire her şey yani bir ilkokul 1 sınıf
çocuğun yapabilecek şeyleri yapmaya
başlamıştım bu direnç ilk okuldaki bu
direnç Ya 2 sene devam etti 3-9 yaşıma
geldiğimde 3 sene artık insafa geldiler
mahalle'ye yakın bir ilkokuldan
bahsediyorum okula bir şekilde
kaydedildim imtiyazı vesaire vesaire
Okul hayatım böyle başladı Okul hayatım
devam ederken Tabii ki bu
Sabahtan beri hep böyle farklı hikayeler
dinliyorsunuz amacım sizi duygulandırmak
üzmek falan değil Şimdi bazıları diyor
ya Çocukluğum çok mutlu geçti aslında
ben çocuklukta o kadar enteresan bir
temponun içerisindeydim ki belki de
Mutluluğu bile bilmiyordum
okula adaptasyonu derken
Ortaokulda artık ergenlikle tanışıyordum
ve Sokağa çıkmam daha fazla olmaya
başlamıştı bütün kıyafetlerim cepliğiydi
ve asla kısa kollu tişört giymezdim eve
misafir geldiğinde benimle hiç
karşılaşmazdı veya Annem misafirliğe
gitmek istediğinde ben hep bir mazeret
uydururdum gitmemek için Çünkü her
bir başka biriyle temasında şu soruyla
karşılaşırdım
Aa ne oldu sor beni sürekli cevaplamak
zorunda bırakan bir durumdu bazen buna
sabırla cevap verirdim Bazen çok
kaçardım Dolayısıyla bu sorularla
muhatap olmamak için olabildiğince
kendimi İçime kapanık tamamen kendi
dünyamda yaşamaya karar vermiştim ama
bir taraftan da içimi devam ettiriyordum
yine böyle
lise 1 sınıfta okul sonrasında eve git
gel kısmını trenle yapıyordum 3 istasyon
ötedeydi evimiz tren istasyonunda Treni
bekliyorum
üzerimde o zaman bilmiyorum İçinizde
Karşıyaka Aksoy Gazi Lisesi'ni bilen var
mı İşte onu bir forması ekoseli falan
falan örgülü saçlar
bankta otururken birden eteğime bir lira
düştü Bir sağa sola baktım acaba para
benden miydi Az önce bilet aldım diye
bir şaşırdım İşin gerçeği Fakat
o para bana ait değildi karşıda bir karı
koca çift bana bakarak yürüyorlardı Ben
kalktım parayı aldım götürdüm
Afedersiniz bu para size mi ait dedim
hanımefendi Çok sıkılarak özür diledi
çok özür dilerim dedi daha fazla bozuk
olsaydı daha fazla bırakacaktım üzerimde
sadece bu vardı dedi Ben de kendisine
ama ben öğrenciyim Bakın bu etek elbise
işte gömlek falan kadın mahcup oldu ama
orada esas Kırılma Noktası benim içindi
bir karar vermem gerekiyordu Tam da
orasıydı bu yaşanması gereken bir olaydı
benim için şöyle dedim anneme tabii ki o
Buhran işte Sizde şu anda bunu belki
kısmen hissedebiliyorsunuz o stresli
ortam yani içinde bulunduğum psikoloji
tam ergenliğin böyle bir durum falan
derken eve gittim anneme bu hikaye
anlattım Annem bana dedi ki
biz dedi çocukken Tabii motivasyon
veriyor işte bir takım iyi güzel
sözlerle benim bu durumumu geçiştirmeye
çalışıyor yapabileceği Başka da bir şey
yok zaten
biz dedi çocukken
4 kız kardeştik dedi ve
anneannen bizi dedi buğday tarlasını
biçmek için götürürdü dedi bizi motive
etmek için
eteğinden
elmaları çıkartır tanrının tam ortasına
atardı Biz o elmalara ulaşabilmek için
gayretle bize düşen kısmı orakla bir
elma bulurduk ve o elma bizim
hayatımızdaki en lezzetli elmaydı derdi
Annem sonra tekrar bir daha bir elma
atardı O bizim motive eden bir şeydi
ve o hikaye benim hayatımı gerçekten
değiştiren bir hikaye oldu o gün bir
karar verdim ya gerçekten toplumda o
dönemde bize bir şeyler rol o bankadaki
karşılaştığım durum Ya da hakikaten
Dizlerimin üstüne kalkıp hayatımla
ilgili eğitimle ilgili nasıl bir yön
vereceğim ve elmayı nereye atmam
konusunda hangi tercihi yapacağımdı ve
ben de kendi elmamı hukuk fakültesinin
bahçesine attım
Evet
dediğim gibi oldukça zor bir süreçti Ama
siz de
toplumda engelli bir bireyin var olması
mücadele etmesi kariyer planlamasını
yapabilmesi için Ekstra bir Efor sarf
etmesi gerekiyor Ayrıca tabii ki
birincil öğretmeni olan anne ve babanın
rolü burada çok önemli Evet çok iyi
üniversitelerde eğitim almış bir anne
babaya sahip değildim ama çok doğru
desteği manevi desteği alan veren bir
aileye sahiptim O nedenle annemi hep
rahmetle yad ediyorum
Hayatımdaki en iyi öğretmen oydu Belki
de dönem dönem insanların kararlarının
değiştiğini ve yol haritasını
değiştirmesi gereken zamanlar oluyordur
bir tanesi benim üniversite hayatım oldu
Hayatımda sadece Coğrafya dersinde
bildiğim
haberlerde o dönem aşırı derecede
izlediğim DJ Üniversitesi hukuk
fakültesinin bahçesinde buldum kendimi
daha önceki konuşmacımız dedi ya 18 tane
tercih yaptım 18 çıktı diye Ben sadece 7
tercih yapmıştım ama 7 çıkmış
ve Diyarbakır'a gittiğimde hakikaten
İzmir Karşıyaka'da yetişmiş bir çocuktum
kültür farklı
1995'ten bahsediyorum Diyarbakır'ın hiç
dinamikleri çok farklı bir yakınımız
bana dedi ki Ya sen hem öğrencisin gel
dedi Çalış bir yerde de parttayım çalış
dedi yakınım da orada çalışıyordu olur
mu
Tamam dedim ve Fransız firmasıyla
tanışmam o karar Sonrası oldu
Diyarbakır'da petrol üretimi yapan
Fransızlara sahip olduğu dünyanın 14
ülkesinden bir tanesi olan firma ile
tanıştım işte intervi yapmak için
personele gittik falan personel tabi
heyecanlıyım yapabilir miyim O da var
çatlak İngilizce bir şeyler yapmaya
çalışıyorum o dönem ve akabinde personel
müdürü dedi ki ya bizim ciğeri var dedi
İngiliz Pro
Öğlen yemeği yemek istiyor sözleşmeyi
imzalamadan önce
[Müzik]
ve akabinde işte Bizde her iki yılda bir
şeyle ona bağlı olarak da kademe kademe
Sonuçta en üst düzey yönetici olarak
oradan Emekli oldum Ama bu arada tabi
evlilik süreci başladı yaş geldi 28-29
akranlarım evleniyor Acaba ben de
evlenebilir miyim sorusunu bir soruyorum
Bir sormuyorum Çünkü o çalışma ortamı da
bir anlamda izole bir yerde çok
insanlarla içli dışlı olduğum bir ortam
değildi açıkçası derken eşimle tanıştım
toplumun bizlere Tabii ki yerleştirdiği
bir model var yani engelli bir kadınsan
engelli bir adamla evlenirsin genel
geçer Kural böyledir size bir rol
Vermişler zaten birileri bunu vermiş ama
tam tersi Benim eşim bir aşiret kocaman
büyük bir ailesi var ve o büyük 11
Kardeşler O büyük ailedeki erkeklere de
seçilen gelin modellerini az çok tahmin
ediyorsunuzdur zaten son zamanlarda
dizilerde bunu bir şekilde anlatıyor
mükemmel gelin modelleri aranır Bu oyunu
güzel falan falan boy Yok öyle postu da
değilim
yani parmakları olmayan bir kadının
eşimde hakikaten
saygınlığı olan işte bilinen tanınan
gösterişli bir beyefendi şimdi böyle bir
beyefendi ile evlenmek nasıl olur biz
böyle bir karar aldık Evlenme kararı
aldık Bütün aile bir duvar gibi önümüze
geçti
türlü türlü mazeretler vesaire vesaire
ama günün sonu eşim Hayatımdaki en
önemli yanımda her konuda destek olan
dağ gibi duran ve çok önemli bence
insanın Kader arkadaş hayat arkadaşı
gerçekten çok çok önemli Hani
hayatımdaki Kahramanlar dediğimde annem
babam ve eşim en önemli kahramanlardan
bir tanesi benim için gerçekten
inanılmaz bir dirençle bu kararından
vazgeçmeyeceğini ve benimle evlenme
evleneceğini söyledi Herkes artık
biliyor bir kısım yas tutuyor bir kısım
şaşkın bir kasın tuhaf tuhaf Duygu
karmaşası içerisinde derken biz evlendik
ve iki çocuk dünyaya getirdim
bir oğlum bir kızım var oğlum 13 yaşında
kızım 14 yaşında ve yine çok da vaktim
kalmadan hemen sizi de yormadan çok
Çünkü
yoruldunuzu düşünüyorum
akabinde ben
yine bir iş seyahatinde uçakta
üniversitedeki hocamla karşılaştım Fatma
ne yapıyorsun Efendim işte şurada
çalışıyorum Şu pozisyonlardayım her şeyi
rahat işte evimde ekonomik sıkıntım yok
ama dedi Senin için en önemli şey rol
üstlendiği rol dedi Sen diğer
arkadaşlarına diğer Kader arkadaşların
için bir yol gösterici olman lazım Evet
suyun üstünde olabilirsin çok iyi bir
işin var çok iyi bir yaşam koşullarım
var ama senin gibi olan birçok kişi için
bir rol olması gerekiyor model olması
gerekiyor Neden Siyasette yer almıyorsun
dediler
Allah Allah dedim O zaman şimdi üçüncü
elmanın atılmaz zamanı ilk elma
üniversite için attım ikincisi evlilik
için attım o zaman dedim Bir tane de
siyaset için atacağım elmayı ve
gerçekten attım tam bir elma atma olayı
gibiydi
hocamın yönlendirmesiyle hiç bilmiyorum
parti üyeliği başladı Sonra bir baktım
adayım Sonra bir baktım genel merkezde
görev aldım ve 11 yıl partinin farklı
kademelerinde farklı görevlerim oldu
yakın zamanda da yine Ankara'dan bir
adaylığım söz konusu oldu akabinde de
eskiden bizi siyasetteki büyük
abilerimiz
ilk başladığım dönemlerde şöyle cümleler
kurarlardı derlerdi işte Uçağa binerken
arandım bakan oldum Ben de hep şunu
derdim Hadi canım
Ama gerçekten
Gecenin bir vakti Hiç bilmediğim bir
numara hiç aklımda yokken Parti üstü
splin kurulunda Avukat olduğum için yer
alıyordum
bir bilmediğim bir numara beni aradı
açtım Hatta bir tereddüt halindeyim
açsam mı açmasam mı 12 müekkil falan
olabilir vesaire gibi kaygılarımız da
var Avukat olanlar bilir iş biraz
handikaplıdır
açtım merhaba dedi Ben Hasan Doğan Ben
hala biri ben hani şaka yapıyor
zannediyorum Aa Buyurun dedim Hayırlı
olsun bakan olarak atandı Bakan
yardımcısı olarak atandınız dedi Ben de
nereye dedim
dedi ki ne demek Nereye Aile ve Sosyal
Hizmetler Bakanlığına dedi tabi çok
şaşırdım politikada görünürlük açısından
da Türkiye'de gerçekten ama gerçekten
başta sizlerin güçlü iradesiyle Biz
görünür olmaya başladık Ve çok önemli
projelerde yer alan çok kıymetli engelli
kardeşlerim var Bunlar her geçen gün
sizlerin yol açmasıyla destek olmasıyla
çok daha fazla yer almaya başlıyor Bu
açıdan gelecek Gerçekten benim için çok
büyük umut verici süreyi de çok fazla
aşmadan
gerçekten ama gerçekten bugün burada
bizleri de davet ettiğiniz için tdx
ekibi de çok teşekkür ediyorum çünkü çok
anlamlı benim Kader arkadaşlarımın
faydasını olacak bir program Onlar benim
Kader arkadaşlarım bakanlıkta görev
yaptığım yaklaşık 9 aydayım 15 Temmuz
itibariyle atandım her gün ama her gün
onlarla beraber olduğum için çok mutlu
hissediyorum kendimi
ve her birinin hikayesini dinlerken de
kendim onlarla birlikte yaşıyorum Umarım
Sizler de bu alanda hassasiyetleriniz
aynı seviyede olur ve Yine diyorum çok
fazla uzatmak istemeden Umuyorum ki
sizin de hayatınızda sadece ve sadece
bir elmayı ısırdığınızda Bu bir yazarın
sözü ama sizi alıntı olarak yapıyorum
karşılaşacağımız kötülük o ısırdığınız
Elmada minicik kurdun çıkardı kafası
olur hayatımız sizin için hep güzel olur
dediğim gibi insanın kendini anlatması
çok zor Ben dilimin döndüğünce
hikayemi sizlere böyle aktarmaya
çalıştım beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ediyorum
ve saygılarımı sunuyorum